this next story is just one of the most
ridiculous and stupid things that has
happened during the Trump presidency and
that I mean it takes a lot for something
to make that standard Donald Trump
yesterday during an Oval Office briefing
about hurricane durian held up an
obviously doctored weather chart that
suggested that hurricane durian could
have hit or was on track to hit Alabama
now you might say why is that something
that even matters to Donald Trump this
is all too retro actively defend Donald
Trump's tweet from a few days ago
warning Alabama about the hurricane when
Alabama wasn't at risk Trump holds up
one of those big blown-up images this is
the hurricane track for hurricane Dorian
and something looks weird on it take a
look and see if you notice it in the
video if you're just listening to the
show today don't worry I'm going to
describe it in detail right afterwards
we thought we'd give you a update on the
hurricane we got lucky in Florida very
very lucky indeed we had actually our
original chart was that it was going to
be hit hitting Florida directly maybe I
could just see that Kevin it was going
to be hitting directly was affected a
lot of other states but that was the
original
not only Florida but Georgia I could
have was going toward the Gulf that was
what we originally projected and took
the right turn so in the video when
Trump holds up this image it looks like
a Sharpie was used to add in a different
different hurricane track that included
Alabama to provide cover for Donald
Trump having previously tweeted that
Alabama was in danger when it wasn't
which of course resulted in mass
confusion in the state of Alabama it
resulted in Weather Service's saying
Alabama is not at risk you don't need to
evacuate your okay if you're in Alabama
other than obviously the completely
horrible social infrastructure social
service infrastructure that exists as
far as the weather I guess I mean you
were okay in Alabama at the time this is
not even remotely funny this is
extraordinarily disturbed behavior so
now let's look at these images in detail
this is the original map that was
published the one from actual weather
people and as you can see the track
simply does not include Alabama as a
place that's at risk and then here is
another version of the same image that
was held up by Donald Trump with a black
circle potentially a sharpie used to
draw a draw in a section of the Florida
Panhandle and pieces of Alabama which is
totally and completely bogus it happens
to be a crime to issue or publish an
incorrect or counterfeit weather report
from the US legal code 18 US Code
subsection 20 74 called false weather
reports says whoever knowingly issues or
publishes any counterfeit weather
forecast or warning of weather
conditions falsely representing such
forecast or warning to have been issued
or published by the weather bureau
United States signal service or other
branch of government service shall be
fined under this title or imprisoned not
more than 90 days or both
just another crime under the trump
administration no big deal there are
many now someone actually asked Donald
Trump during a subsequent media
availability about the word about a
Sharpie being used for this to be drawn
and Trump just kind of stuttered
and looked away and said he doesn't know
about that I don't know I don't know I
don't know I don't know think for a
second if the Trump administration is
willing to go this far for some you know
offhanded stupid incorrect tweet from
Donald Trump about a hurricane and
Alabama how far are they willing to go
in other areas and how far are they
going in other areas that were simply
not hearing about because every day is
lies and scandals and deception and
misdirection the lengths to which this
administration goes to avoid simply
owning up to a small mistake I mean
would it be that bad would it be that
crazy if we just had a statement from
Donald Trump
you know I didn't mean to alarm people
that didn't need to be alarmed there was
a point very early on where I believed
from the briefing I got that it was
possible that the hurricane was going to
Alabama that possibility was no longer a
possibility when I sent the tweet didn't
mean to - you know disturb people this
was a very damaging storm regardless and
were were right you you could just admit
it but there is something that goes on
in the guy's brain and it has spread
like a virus to the people around him
where everybody knows you can never back
down you double down you don't back down
and this time they used a sharpie to
double down this is comically insane
except it's not comical and it's not
actually insane in that this would be an
insult to insane people and I don't want
to do that this is also not criminal
genius this is struggling for what what
to call it
this is malignant criminal narcissism
and idiocy maybe is the way that I would
sum it up and fortunately Fox News is
not allowing this to go unnoticed let's
talk about that next